hello bioinformatics enthusiasts let's
talk about how you can access the omics
logic learn portal and start your
bioinformatics journey
all you need to do is go to the omics
logic learn portal here's the website
learn.omicslogic.com
on the portal you'll see the login
option just click on it and you can sign
in
and if you don't have an account you can
sign up for free and create one
simply type in your name
your email and set a password
you can also sign up with any of your
social media accounts and then sign in
using any of these which you have signed
up with
after that you have to complete your
profile by providing your phone number
the country that you're in your
occupation and what university you're in
as i already have an account i'm going
to sign in
the next step is to update your profile
this is a crucial step click on your
email id on the menu bar this will lead
you to the profile section
an updated profile is also necessary for
the mentors to monitor your progress so
make sure you have an updated profile
you can upload your picture your name
should be in the title case as the same
will reflect on your certificates
link your social media accounts and add
a brief bio about yourself your research
background and your research interests
you're all set to access the resources
on the portal
on the left side you can see the level
you're at
your points and your subscription
initially when you start you won't have
any points you can gain them by
completing steps of asynchronous courses
the first two courses are completely
free do check them out and start
learning
here you can see your activity and then
by clicking on the course you can see
the courses and the percentage you have
completed
you can also see the programs you're
enrolled in
you can access the projects once you
have reached a milestone of 10 000
points
and here you can see the certificates of
courses that you have completed
so that's it you're all set happy
learning